hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action un leaches I'm trying to do
one video per day uh in order to improve
a little bit and also in order to help
out some of you guys that are perhaps on
your way to becoming better players and
um higher rated players to you know uh
grasp General understanding of the game
so while I I will not be playing at the
level of the players that they usually
cover uh I do play uh some nice moves on
occasion so let's check it out our
opponent is uh let me just check out the
Z mode Mr doc
Livy um from Russia and we are going to
challenge him with Pawn to E4 all right
let's see what he what he does Pawn E5
all right Knight to F3 the standard
stuff here uh do we get some EV action
no we're we're going to go for the
standard pretty much everyone plays this
if if they go into it uh and I already
played one game I believe uh in during
my uh rapid uh game and Lees sometimes I
go Bishop D3 sometimes I go Bishop E2
also you can play Queen F3 it's a fun
line but it doesn't really do all that
much for white so we're going to go for
the standard stuff now probably some H6
E4 action and then well then it all
depends on what black decides to play uh
but E4 is pretty standard and now
something like Bishop D6 or queen to C7
I even seen Queen to D6 although that's
that's just weird
so we'll see what what Mr doc doc goes
for uh the the idea is of course black
gave up a pawn but black has very rapid
development and black will try to use
that development to put pressure on
White's position and uh you know
eventually either get a winning position
or or win the material back so something
will have to happen and I will try to
Castle the safety I will try to fet on
my dark Square Bishop this way and if I
can do that then perhaps move my queen
from D1 uh that also is sometimes a
problem in this uh opening uh as he he
will move the bishop Castle King side
move the queen and then put a rook on d8
having my queen on D1 could be very
annoying uh but okay I think for for uh
for the first time in a very long time
we are actually ahead on the clock so
that makes me very happy I'm not always
the one uh thinking a lot yeah Queen D4
um
I've perhaps I've seen the move uh at
some
point uh but okay
regardless uh so the point is we we
cannot retreat with the knight uh so we
we'll probably have to play Pawn to F4
and then if I play Pawn to F4 he can
play Bishop to D6 and then I get to kick
away the queen with C3 or something like
that uh but I'm pretty sure F4 is the
move I play but what if what if F4
Bishop
C5 is that a
move yeah looks very very
strange
um
yeah okay let's play Pawn to4 it's
pretty much the only move white has
unless I'm mistaken and he will probably
go for Bishop to C5 but we're going to s
it but yeah already he he plays a move I
don't know already I lose a
minute pretty pretty pretty crazy
stuff yeah okay he he will play
that and uh we will
go we will go
what yeah I don't see anything I didn't
see anything other than F4 and Rook to
to F1 to counter this
idea I will check it out after the game
we're going to we're going to analyze it
uh with the leeches analysis tool but um
yeah definitely something you should
know by heart if you if you play this
line uh but we'll see okay my king is in
the center of the board but now I'm
playing C3 and he will have problems
because now he can't just do whatever if
if he allows C3 and B4 he's going to
lose a piece so he has to move the queen
now
and then I get to play D4
maybe yeah maybe this is
uh yeah or he will play that yeah uh but
we're still going to play C3
probably probably we
will and then the queen goes
where he just blocked his Queen's
Retreat okay the queen can go six here
obviously
yeah we're going to play
C3 um and then after Queen to B6 which I
imagine is the only
move yeah B4 uh will not okay Queen D5
also yeah Queen B6 would actually be bad
due to B4 then he can't capture due to
captures yeah but Queen D5 definitely
so now if I have time for B4 he kicking
away the Knight and Bishop C4 that
should be very good for me but if I play
B4 he will just capture here but no that
can't be done then I capture and I'm
threatening well yeah B4 is just winning
as as it often is so I imagine this is
winning yeah he will show me if it's
not I mean he could even give up a piece
maybe for some kingside play with uh
capturing on H2 and the Knight and
Bishop
here uh but I don't think so yeah let's
capture df7
Pawn Yeah I I have a feeling whenever I
um no we're not just capturing the F7
point we actually want is Queen yeah
that's why Bishop to D6 was uh
yeah I think both of us realized that uh
the F7 Pawn was uh was going to fall but
we didn't realize that he was also
blundering his
Queen so what is Bishop G4 is this
anything
no now it's uh now it's time to move
with
uh with
Elegance like Que Queen B3 is fine but
maybe Queen to C6 is even
better it's hard to decide since it's
hard to decide since I'm going to win
his Queen to actually play something
what is
better yeah but this puts kind of
additional pressure on F7 but this also
puts pressure on
C6 yeah this is the real question we're
going to win this game but uh how how
well do we want to win
it that's the question
because if I play this he might have
some tricky moves like Knight to C5
attacking my queen and if I capture he
saves his Queen and then I capture on F7
so it's better to just not move the
queen anywhere near that Knight so maybe
not B3 and
A4 uh maybe just Queen C2 and be done
with
it yeah let's not be greedy yeah Queen
C2 and that's pretty much
it now he will play something like
Bishop captures on
E5 um and I will have a winning Position
will I win it that's uh that's a
different
story hope I
will Mr
doc yeah that was uh that was that was
actually very
nice you know I I was I was going after
the pawn and I sort of
uh grab his Queen along the way it's
like you know I'm aling the the
queen uh but yeah if he if he doesn't
feel like it you know maybe he will just
go let's just play another game maybe he
resigns but uh if he if he feels that
maybe he can play of course he will try
okay he he will capture with the queen
on E5 we're going to take and uh yeah
now let's uh
is there a way to now put pressure on
the position yeah okay now now I can
play something like Queen to A4 to put
pressure
but I'm guessing something like D4 would
be better
suited have to develop
first yeah probably just captures
captures castles and then we continue
the game he has some compensation but
not
uh not nothing that nothing
serious
um okay let's capture
here our King is still in the center
which of course can be annoying
but once Bishop to F4 lands should be
okay yeah okay now he
can
H yeah might not be that
simple uh yeah
H yeah I think I actually have to play
H3 as ugly as it looks but then Rook ad
d8 I kind of have to move the queen and
then he has
this wow this looks really ugly this
looks really
ugly
h
yeah this is much much harder than
expected actually have to play Rook
F2 to
avoid but no now Rook ad8 is just mate
wow I actually I actually set up a mate
for
myself that is truly
amazing okay he can win the queen back
now but
uh and then it's and then it's just an
equal game wow with with me being up a
pawn maybe that's how maybe that's how
it should have should have
gone yeah this okay so he doesn't want
to do it of course why should he he
wants to play Bishop G3 now so we're not
going to allow
that and now Rook f8 we have we have
this no that would be terrible we
actually have to play
this wow this is so
bad yeah we can't play
that
yeah Rook f8 I have to play Bishop B2
yeah
okay I really wonder what was the
correct continuation there it it really
didn't seem like I had all that much may
maybe just Queen to C2 was um was too
passive maybe I just wanted to avoid
calculating uh Queen B3 and queen A4 and
then I ran into
problems but it's uh it's it's actually
what happens quite often when I play
this line it seems like I'm doing okay
and then you know uh being undeveloped
on the queen side just starts kicking in
and it's very hard to
play okay he I mean then this is a
pretty bad piece but all of the other
pieces are
excellent so far I mean it's kind of
like I'm hanging by a threat here now
maybe maybe he should have went for for
the queen maybe maybe I'm actually
defending this now
uh
because he will have to trade down and
as soon as he trades
down yeah now he definitely has to do it
he definitely has to do it
now yeah he will do
it all right now W The Exchange he's up
a
pawn and yeah of course he he he he
becomes very active we're going to go
here no we're not that would blunder a
rook
actually um yeah that's
annoying but we can go here yeah here
we're guarding everything we're guarding
this and
this and we're going to threaten this
and then we hope to play C4 before we
finally develop our Queen
side which is kind of the the theme of
this game yeah he has to waste the move
developing this Knight although not
right away yeah we're going to we're
going to play this uh as it will now
come with
Tempo so I just have to make sure not to
blunder anything and we're
good okay here we're covering
everything now we activate the Knight
and the rook and we hopefully stop uh
stop with with silly
moves yeah I'm I'm really okay it's uh
important to focus on the game as well
but I I don't think I'll be able to mess
this up now uh so I'm very much looking
forward to analyzing
this probably something
really uh trivial okay so he does have
that
okay you can trade yeah okay okay one
more Pawn he can take a
pawn he can take a pawn
but
how maybe okay so he defends this of
course he does uh let's put pressure on
this guy here where will the Knight go
okay the Knight goes to
B5 then we play A4 then he goes Knight
D4 or
something now he goes here he wants to
always be in range of my king okay so we
can go here so this is annoying for him
at all
times let's go
here yeah The Rook must be
strong yeah let's take this with
check uh let's go
here
[Music]
mhm of course he wants to be very tricky
with the Knights uh but I'm also very
happy to just trade
here I'm very happy to just trade
here
uh okay what is this what is this how is
he saving the Knight if I go Knight
C5 yeah he's
not now we now we get the trade and we
win the pawn as
well
yeah it'd be great if I had something
better but I don't think I do
so now we're going to try and uh just to
make sure and uh so so I don't have to
calculate too much we're going to
win or or at least try to win one more
Pawn uh yeah
okay let's go after after the
Knight
and okay now can I give a check and pick
up the pawn am I in danger of any checks
no this is a check but it's uh far away
from my Rook so we can take the
pawn H here he starts advancing the pawn
it's fine our our Pawn is now
Unstoppable
okay yeah was uh
very
interesting yeah okay we don't have to
over calculate it we can just Advance
this
okay he wants to be persistent until the
end and you should I mean as long as
there's a knight there's a
way yeah there we go all
right he will still play this okay no he
won't thought maybe maybe there was
going to be some sort of a stalemate but
yeah let's uh let's check it out our
good friend the engine we're firing it
up uh so we're okay this is all
perfectly fine yeah we know this is fine
we know this fine now Queen D4 so F4 we
played it nicely Bishop C5 and now Rook
F1 so those are the only moves we play
that correctly Bishop D6 C3 okay it says
C3 or D3 but this is fine
B4 uh strongest by the engine uh of
course every time Knight B to7 yeah now
this is a mistake Bishop C4 uh yeah just
capturing the queen is also perfectly
fine you don't have to move the queen
but then he captures yeah and uh Rook
captures on F6 say the engine uh just
get rid of the defender of E4 yeah I was
uh I was kind of overthinking this but
yeah it's still perfectly fine and now
H3 yeah pretty much uh uh why I didn't
play H3 I did consider it I didn't like
it for some reason I thought uh yeah
just rook f8 and then uh it'd be too
hard to defend but H3 yeah H3 Rook F to
E8 and then King to D2 says our good
friend the engine
what
H3 Rook f8 King to D2 and now what
happens if you just do this oh you just
give back the queen so okay so you you
kind of have to give up the queen
doesn't matter how you play it I play
Rook F2 which is still uh maybe not
winning for white but still much better
yeah and now still Rook captures on F6
yeah this is always in the
works yeah now Bishop D2 is sort of
still better for
me and uh yeah I have a slight Edge in
the end game okay were there any
blunders throughout the end game let me
just quickly check okay so this was fine
this was fine this was
fine yeah not not terrible completely
winning yeah winning winning
winning uh yeah okay so we didn't we
didn't mess anything up so okay it was
it was not uh not the best but we
after we went into all of this um wild
stuff we were never worse we were pretty
much always better and at one point he
equalized here yeah but
uh uh this D4 completely unnecessary
just Rook captures on F6 G captures and
queen captures on e4 and his entire
position falls apart yeah that's how you
should have concluded it and then
D4 yeah making it impossible for him to
just uh get the Rooks he loses the
bishop and yeah that was that was the
actual solution to the position uh not
the the horrid stuff that I played uh
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh yeah now I also will
remember for you know future references
how to how to play this queen to D4 line
just F4 and now C3 or D3 after Rook F1
and white should be perfectly fine but
yeah if if you want to play this you
have to know all of these lines they're
disgusting and uh if you don't know them
at least if I don't know them I will
waste a lot of time and I mean this is a
rapid game we have 10 minutes and I've
spent uh all all the time uh basically
on the first few moves of the game but
yeah once again hope you enjoyed it and
uh yeah uh we're continuing tomorrow
with some more rapid action uh stay
tuned and if you have any openings that
you would like to see me play do use
ashtag suggestion and I will do my best
to to try and to to try to try them out
uh see you soon